juego cruzado en indoniesk así vive
buena parte de los ciudadanos ucranianos
residentes en el este del país las
fuerzas de kiev bombardearon la región
controlada por Rusia
según las autoridades prorusas de la
zona fue un hostigamiento masivo no
visto desde 2014
atacaron el primer edificio hace tres
días No entiendo a qué viene todo esto
por qué no se puede demostrar nada con
esto porque los que viven en don Bach
los que son de doniets son leales
adonietskales a Rusia no puede verse de
otra manera el alcalde local respaldado
por Moscú afirmó que al menos unos 40
cohetes fueron disparados desde
lanzaderas múltiples se reportaron menos
de una decena de heridos escuché un
fuerte estruendo y vi algo como una gran
bola de fuego cayendo justo al frente al
balcón Todo comenzó a caer sobre mi cama
vidrio pedazos de ladrillos o todo
Moscú también efectuó bombardeos en la
ciudad de gersón según funcionarios
ucranianos el ataque dejó víctimas
mortales Mientras tanto continúan los
enfrentamientos en autobuses conducidos
por voluntarios han evacuado a la
mayoría de la población allí los
residentes se enfrentan bombardeos a
diario de los 70.000 ciudadanos en la
zona tan solo quedan unas mil personas
los enfrentamientos continuarán según el
portavoz del kremlin Dimitri piscoff no
estaba agendado un alto al fuego por las
fiestas de fin de año